viacrucis con rumbo al norte de llegar a
Estados Unidos
partieron de las ureña ciudad de
Tapachula fronteriza con Guatemala hacia
la Ciudad de México allí intentarán
acelerar los trámites de su solicitudes
de asilo en Estados Unidos Los
Caminantes esperan llegar en unos 10
días a la capital mexicana pues adelante
nada de rendirnos A dónde quiere llegar
usted Patricia pues alto a lo que Todos
queremos hasta los Estados Unidos luchar
y luchar para un mejor futuro para mi
niña Hay una que dejé allá en Honduras
también los integrantes de la Caravana
también están exigiendo justicia por los
40 migrantes muertos en el incendio de
un puesto de detención en Ciudad Juárez
el pasado 27 de marzo estamos
protestando por las cuarenta muertes de
Ciudad Juárez para que cierran los
institutos de migración para que el
presidente Obrador mire que realmente es
una una buena causa que destituyan al
director de migración porque son estos
son los campos de concentración en los
búnkeres de este siglo en este sentido
un jefe Regional de la autoridad
migratoria Mexicana fue detenido y
acusado de presunto homicidio por el
siniestro de Ciudad Juárez El
funcionario identificado como Salvador
González dirigía el Instituto Nacional
de Migración en el estado de Chihuahua
se espera que la Caravana llegue hasta
la Basílica de la Virgen de Guadalupe
según la agencia de protección de
fronteras y aduanas de Estados Unidos en
el año fiscal 2023 más de un millón 200
migrantes llegaron a la zona limítrofe
en el año fiscal 2022 esa cifra superó
las dos billones trescientas mil
personas